esta vez tenemos un par de ejemplos
donde nos dan un ángulo su magnitud y su
dirección y ojo la dirección nos la dan
con un ángulo positivo que se forman a
partir del lado positivo del eje x y lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
dada esta información es decir dada su
magnitud y este ángulo su dirección
quiero encontrar cuáles son sus
componentes x y james de este vector y
como siempre te pido que pausas el vídeo
y veas si puedes resolver este ejercicio
por tu cuenta
ok vamos a trabajarlo juntos y bueno en
el procedimiento estará involucrada la
trigonometría porque cuando rompamos
este vector en sus componentes
verticales y horizontales o dicho de
otra manera estos componentes equis y
james nos vamos a encontrar con un
triángulo rectángulo es más vamos a
hacerlo esto se va a ver más o menos así
voy a decir que mi componente x se va a
ver más o menos
más o menos como por aquí más o menos
así se ve mi componente x así que
déjenme poner que este es mi componente
x y mi componente james se va a ver
déjame hacerlo con este color se va a
ver de la siguiente manera se va a ver
más o menos
así de lujo entonces déjame poner que
esta es mi componente y observa que si
tú sumas la componente x más la
componente de este vector es decir su
componente horizontal más su componente
vertical entonces llegas a tu vector
original obtienes su vector original y
también quiero que observes que acabamos
de construir un triángulo rectángulo
este es un triángulo rectángulo que
vamos a ocupar para obtener los
componentes de este vector y bueno como
tengo un triángulo rectángulo entonces
puedo usar las definiciones de las
funciones trigonométricas es decir las
definiciones del sujeto am y recuerdan
que todo esto viene de las definiciones
del círculo unitario que tal vez utilice
más adelante pero si quiero obtener la
magnitud de la base que tengo aquí es
decir de este lado entonces puedo ver
que este es el cateto adyacente a este
ángulo de 50 grados no es la hipotenusa
pero es el otro lado que forman este
ángulo de 50 grados entonces qué función
cuando me involucran al adyacente y a la
hipotenusa bueno pues recordemos anchoa
y si te das cuenta el coche no es el que
involucra al adyacente con la hipotenusa
así que puedo decir que si este lado de
aquí que vamos a ponerle un nombre
supongamos que se llama x si llamo a
esta longitud x entonces podemos decir
que el coche no déjame ponerlo aquí que
el coche no de este ángulo de 50 grados
de este ángulo de 50 grados va a ser
igual a la longitud del adyacente que en
este caso es x x entre la longitud la
hipotenusa que ya sabemos que es 4 entre
4 muy bien y si ahora multiplicó por 4
ambos lados de esta ecuación voy a
obtener que cuatro veces el coseno de
cincuenta grados cuatro veces el coseno
de 50 grados esto va a ser igual a x a
lo que estoy buscando
y ahora si pensamos en la componente
bien que hay de la componente y bueno
pues la componente ya está de aquí va a
ser el lado opuesto a este ángulo de 50
grados así que cuál es la función
trigonométricas que involucra al lado
opuesto ya la hipotenusa es el seno está
de acuerdo entonces sabemos que el seno
seno de este ángulo de 50 grados va a
ser igual a la longitud del cateto
opuesto que sabemos que es bien entre la
longitud de la hipotenusa que sabemos
que es 4 y otra vez si multiplicamos a
ambos lados por 4 voy a tener que cuatro
veces el seno de 50 grados es lo mismo
que esta componente ya de lujo y si no
tuviéramos calculadora puedo escribir a
este vector que tengo aquí con sus
respectivas componentes porque ya
sabemos que su componente x sería 4
veces el coste no de 54 veces el coseno
de 50 grados y la componente ya sería
cuatro veces el seno de 50 grados cuatro
veces el seno de 50 grados y así podría
describir a este vector con sus
componentes y observa que aquí tenemos
algo muy interesante tengo el coche no
del ángulo que se forma a partir del eje
x
y observa que este coche no nos ayuda a
formar la componente x y en el otro lado
tengo al seno de este ángulo de 50
grados que nos ayuda a formar la
componente hierro y a su vez estas
funciones trigonométricas están siendo
multiplicadas por la magnitud de este
vector y la pregunta es podré hacer esto
siempre y la respuesta es que si esto
sale de la definición de las funciones
trigonométricas del círculo unitario si
por aquí tenemos un círculo unitario
déjame dibujar por aquí un círculo
unitario que se vea más o menos así y me
fijo ahora en un vector que tenga la
misma dirección pero que sea un vector
unitario bueno pues este vector que
tengo aquí va a tener como componente x
alto seno del ángulo que lo forman y
como componente bien al seno del ángulo
que la forma pero bueno no tenemos un
vector unitario tenemos un vector cuya
magnitud es 4 es 4 veces más grande que
el vector unitario así que cada una de
sus componentes será
cuatro veces más grande que las del
vector unitario es por esto que
multiplicamos algo seno de 50 grados por
4 y al seno de 50 grados por 4 y así
obtenemos la componente xy la componente
bien y bueno esto no lo olvides porque
por acá vamos a obtener algo parecido
ahora es momento de poder sacar nuestra
calculadora de aproximar el valor que
vamos a obtener así que por aquí tengo
mi calculadora y manos a la obra no
olvides fíjate que estamos en el modo
que dice de para hablar de los ángulos
en grados y ahora si me quiero tomar
cuatro veces el coche no de 50 pues
vamos a hacerlo 50 a esto le voy a
calcular su coseno y a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por 4 y yo obtengo 2.57
aproximadamente así que déjame ponerlo
por acá nuestros componentes van a ser
aproximadamente bueno mi componente x va
a ser aproximadamente
punto 57 y mi componente y vamos a
trabajarla si saco de nuevo mi
calculadora y pongo 50 y le sacó el seno
a eso y después lo multiplicó por 4
obtengo 3.06 aproximadamente así que
déjame ponerlo aquí y 3.06 ahí está y
con esto podemos ver que por aquí esto
tiene razón porque la componente x se ve
un poco más grande que 12 2.5 va un poco
más allá que 2.5 y la componente ya se
ve 123 un poquito ligeramente más grande
que 3 así que parece que todo cuadra
nada mal para esta gráfica hecha a mano
bien vayamos al siguiente ejercicio a
este de aquí y este es interesante
porque nuestro punto final de este
vector en su forma estándar está en el
segundo cuadrante
así que cuáles sean sus componentes xy
james y seguramente dirás de manera
inmediata que como estamos en el segundo
cuadrante la componente x tiene que ser
negativa y la componente i tiene que ser
positiva bueno pues podemos resolverlo
de la misma manera que lo hicimos en el
ejercicio pasado podemos decir que las
componentes de este vector son la
componente x es la magnitud de este
vector que multiplica al coseno del
ángulo positivo que se forma a partir
del lado positivo de x es decir 135
grados y la componente james se va a
formar como la magnitud que multiplica
al seno de este ángulo 135 grados de
lujo y entonces ya está podemos
evaluarlo
así que si traigo por acá mi calculadora
y digo 135 grados a esto le sacó el
coche no menos 0.70 ya esto lo
multiplicó por 10
obtengo menos 7.07 aproximadamente así
que lo voy a poner por aquí
aproximadamente tengo menos 7.107 coma y
bueno vamos a hacer la componente bien
de nuevo traigo mi calculadora y digo
ahora me voy a tomar el seno de 135
observa es positivo 0.70 positivo ya
esto lo multiplicó por 10 y obtengo 7.07
aproximadamente así que 7.07
aproximadamente y ya está y lo puedes
ver aquí esto se ve un poco más grande
que 7 y un poco más grande que 7 justo
como lo tenemos aquí y lo hemos logrado
y una vez más cómo funciona todo esto
bueno pues es que recuerda que si por
aquí tengo un círculo unitario vamos a
dibujar por aquí mi círculo unitario más
o menos se va a ver de esta forma y
ahora me tomo
un vector que tenga la misma dirección
que este vector grande de color azul
pero que sea un vector unitario que se
vea más o menos así entonces en este
punto de aquí déjame utilizar este color
para que sea más visible este punto de
aquí donde intersecta al círculo
unitario va a tener como coordenadas
coseno de 135 grados seno de 135 grados
esto para este vector unitario que tengo
aquí dicho de otra manera su componente
xv a ser coseno de 135 grados y su
componente james va a ser seno de 135
grados pero el vector que a nosotros nos
importa tiene 10 veces la magnitud de
este vector unitario y está en la misma
dirección entonces su componente x va a
ser 10 veces la componente x del vector
unitario y su componente bien igual y
todo esto viene de las definiciones del
soca tohá así que para que lo veas con
mayor claridad
puedo construir aquí un triángulo
rectángulo se me ocurre que puedo tomar
mi componente xy ponerla por aquí por
aquí voy a tomar mi componente x voy a
suponer que es está por aquí déjenme
poner que esta es mi componente xy bueno
voy a suponer que también tengo por acá
con este color a mi componente y déjame
ponerlo así está aquí es mi componente y
mi componente y aquí se forma un ángulo
recto y bueno si nosotros queremos este
lado de aquí la magnitud de mi base
entonces puedo decir bueno espera nos
falta este ángulo que tengo aquí pero si
te das cuenta de aquí hasta acá tengo un
ángulo de 135 grados y este es
suplementario por lo tanto este es de 45
grados así que en función
trigonométricas involucra al lado
adyacente y a la hipotenusa bueno pues
es el coseno eso quiere decir que el
coseno el co seno de este ángulo de 45
grados
ser igual a bueno este lado que no sea
le voy a poner el nombre de x va a ser x
entre la hipotenusa que vale 10 entre 10
y si multiplicamos ambos lados por 10
entonces nos va a quedar que diez veces
el coseno de 45 grados esto es igual a
equis y bueno el coseno de 45 grados
es lo mismo que raíz de todo sobre 2
entonces si lo multiplicó por 10 me va a
quedar 5 veces la raíz de 2 esto es
igual a equis y en este momento puedes
decir bueno yo esperaba que esto fuera
negativo me recuerda que este es un lado
del triángulo no puede ser negativo y es
por eso que es muy importante que no te
dejes llevar por el impulso y razones un
poco el problema y entonces digas no voy
a ir 5 raíz de 2 a la derecha
voy a ir 5 raíz de 2 a la izquierda por
lo tanto si quiero mi componente x
de este vector que tengo aquí bueno pues
esta va a ser menos cinco veces la raíz
de dos ok y siguiendo un razonamiento
análogo podemos obtener este lado de
aquí podemos decir que este lado de aquí
va a ser diez veces el seno de 45 grados
y bueno el seno de 45 grados es raíz de
2 sobre 2 entonces voy a obtener cinco
veces la raíz de dos ésta va a ser la
magnitud de este lado o dicho de otra
manera la componente de este vector va a
ser cinco veces la raíz de todos y así
de fácil y de sencillo llegamos al
resultado y si tú evalúas en la
calculadora cinco veces la raíz de dos
verás que esto se aproximarán al
resultado que tenemos aquí arriba